it's six o'clock this is sky news live
from buckingham palace on the third day
of national celebrations for the queen's
platinum jubilee
the palace has said that the queen will
miss this year's epsom derby due to
mobility issues newly released footage
from sandringham shows her lifelong love
of horses
the 96 year old monarch is expected to
cheer on her favorite horses on tv at
windsor castle
this evening charles and william will
appear on stage to pay tribute to the
queen at a star-studded jubilee concert
also ahead with members of the royal
family to visit all four nations of the
uk we'll look at what the monarchy means
to wales
and from pomp to punk how the queen has
shaped the culture of the nation
[Music]
also to come this morning in the sport
england face an uphill battle to save
the first test at lords against new
zealand
and we'll review how this morning's
newspapers are reporting the jubilee
celebrations including harry and megan's
appearance at saint paul's yesterday
[Music]
hello good morning from buckingham
palace on the third day of national
celebrations for the queen's platinum
jubilee now later today princess anne
will stand in for her mother at today's
epsom derby the monarch is a passionate
horse owner and breeder and she was due
to be greeted on the course with a
special guard of honour including 40 of
her past and present jockeys instead
she's expected to watch on television at
windsor castle
well here at buckingham palace the stage
is being set for tonight's jubilee
concert and we're told that uh charles
and william will appear on stage later
to pay tribute to the queen at this
start-studded event that's going to have
all sorts of people taking part from
elton john to duran duran that's later
on tonight
so let's take a look ahead to the day
ahead of us i'm joined here by royal
commentator vi countess hitchingbrook
julie montague uh she's going to be with
us throughout the morning so really
lovely to have you with us absolutely so
let's look ahead to today then we've got
the epsom derby this afternoon and we
learned yesterday that sadly the queen's
not going to be there in person
presumably because of those mobility
issues that meant she didn't make the
saint paul's service either
how much of a disappointment do you
think that will be for her i mean we
know that she loves racing and she loves
horses well i think it will be a huge
disappointment just like yesterday was
you know the service of thanksgiving we
know how important religion has really
steered her throughout her 70-year reign
and again horses give her pleasure you
know that's the thing that she
absolutely loves and for her to miss
this you know we must now think that she
really is suffering from mobility issues
to not attend the service yesterday and
of course to not to be there today uh
also to receive you know the award and
the excitement from the crowd so i think
it's a real
i'm sure she's saddened and and in fact
almost heartbroken that she can't but
you know this is the queen celebrations
will still go on and they've released
some pictures today back from april of
the queen with her horses at sandringham
and you don't even need to see those
pictures just to know that she's
passionate you can see her face light up
can't you when you you see her looking
at horses and watching the racing or
whether it's at one of the official
state events exactly and you know these
four day celebrations were really you
know evolved around what the queen loves
you've got the service of thanksgiving
yesterday at st paul's again we know how
important religion is a part of her life
and then today with um with the absent
at epson and i think you know those two
things really sort of stand out um as
when we define and we look at the queen
of what has has guided her in her life
religion but also the things that she
gets such pleasure from which are horses
and so this four-day event really did uh
focus on the things that she loved and
it's a real shame that she will of
course miss it but understandably well
yes and we understand that she was keen
to have that as part of the program over
the four days the other event though of
course that we've got this evening is
being prepared for behind us the state
the stages are literally being being set
in front of buckingham palace i mean
it's going to be a spectacular venue
isn't it yeah for a concert
and tell us a little bit about
what you think the thinking is behind
having a concert like this which has got
a range of different music and i think
we've got lots of sports stars and big
figures like so david attenborough are
expected to to be a part of it what's
what's the ambition with it do you think
well i think the ambition is for all of
us so again this is going to give us the
viewer real pleasure in this as well i
don't think there was really any
expectation that the queen would be here
instead we can we see that prince
charles and prince william will be here
um as well but i think it's really a
span of her 70 years having somebody
like david attenborough there really
does represent uh you know this span of
her first thing he's the same age
actually
yeah
and they're very good friends we know
that so i think again it's a celebration
of these 70 years not just what's
happening now but you know of the past
and sort of memories of the past and
evoking those memories um for all of us
of her 70-year reign and as you say
perhaps reaching out to all age groups
absolutely including everybody
absolutely stay with us because i do
want to take us through um how the
papers are reported on yesterday's
jubilee celebrations let's take a quick
look at them shall we um and starting
with the mirror together yet apart
that's their headline they're referring
to the cambridges and the sussexes all
attending the queen's jubilee service
yesterday but still keeping their
distance
and that's the same story on the front
of the daily mail as well so far apart
is their headline
the times meanwhile has words from the
archbishop of york as he pays tribute to
an absent queen at that st paul's
service
and the service is also on the front of
the express this morning that's the
image there you can see the congregation
the headline is we give thanks
and it's a similar sentiment on the
front of the daily telegraph thank you
for staying at the course as a reference
to the archbishop of york's sermon
and the guardian as says with no queen
in attendance and the next generation of
royals gathering in her place it seems
like we were witnessing a new age for
the monarchy
so it's interesting isn't it what the
papers have chosen to focus on and
perhaps no surprise that a number of
them
really honed in on the fact that we saw
william and harry separated by an aisle
in saint paul's cathedral how do you
think that was handled do you think
there was no choice because the sussexes
are now no longer working royals or do
you think it was sort of practical
thinking we don't want the cameras
focusing in on whether or not they're
going to converse right do you know what
i think it's it's a balancing act right
there i think this is exactly what the
sussexes didn't want they didn't want to
be the center of attention while they're
here and they wake up this morning we
wake up this morning and they're on most
of the front pages you know wondering is
this rift still continuing and that's
probably what they didn't want they have
kept a very low key since uh arriving
here they didn't go to the lunch after
the service of what of thanksgiving at
st paul's yesterday so
you know i think this is something that
the royal family didn't want to see on
the papers they don't want this to be
taking away from the spotlight of this
four-day celebration of of the queen but
alas it has and we see it all over the
papers i think
you know nothing happens by chance i do
think that there was a reason that harry
and megan walked down the aisle
into the church into the cathedral by
themselves that was probably something
that perhaps the queen had suggested
that they weren't walking down with zara
or other cousins but again where they
were seated yes i i'm sure that this was
meticulously planned so that there
weren't any glances so that you know
nobody could catch them on camera um
looking at each other and then looking
away like we have seen before in the
past so i think a lot of it has been
orchestrated
to make sure um that you know the media
didn't get um i think perhaps what many
people were looking for but by having
them separated they're still on the
front page today well yes and and
in some ways they can't win can they i
mean you know if they if they keep a low
profile people say that they're perhaps
a bit you know separated from the royal
family as some of those headlines
suggest if they're too high profile
people say the distraction from the
queen who this weekend is all about
every step megan and harry make here
will at least one while they're in the
public eye and i don't know if we'll
really ever see them again
um everybody's this weekend do you mean
yeah this weekend right this weekend i
don't know if we'll ever see if we will
see them again this weekend i mean there
has been no reports on if they're coming
to the concert this evening um but i
think every step that they make over
these next couple of days are still
going to be watched because people are
looking for the body language they're
looking for the glances they're looking
to see how they communicate um and
that's
again i think that's what the sussex is
wanted to avoid they don't want to be
the center of attention and
again they are they're on the front page
of most of the papers this morning and
this weekend is obviously about
communities coming together to celebrate
these these 70 years this constant
throughout so many of our lives there
are a few of us that remember
the previous monarch but it's also about
family as well isn't it our own families
but also their family i mean
could this be a time of healing of any
rifts and we don't know how deep they
are do we it's all speculation of course
it's all speculation and i think
everybody wants this healing to happen
and perhaps that's why they are you know
splashed on the front pages today
because we didn't get a hint of that
healing we didn't see
you know them mingling with with in
particular william and kate and of
course charles and camilla we didn't see
the sussexes mingling with them they
didn't go to the drinks and the lunch
afterwards and that was an opportunity
for them to again mingle so you do have
to question
what is their relationship and you know
and it's of course it's it's a lot of um
you know who knows it's up in the air
and a lot of guessing and speculation
okay julie for the moment thanks very
much indeed i'm pleased to say you're
not gonna be too far away all morning
but for the moment thank you
so the jubilee celebrations are well
underway as you would have noticed but
let's see what's still to come
across this long weekend
well it's derby day as we said the queen
would usually be expected to attend the
races at epson downs but will be
represented this year by other members
of the royal family
and this evening thousands are expected
to attend a special concert outside
buckingham palace performers include
elton john diana ross and eurovision's
sam ryder
on sunday millions will take part in a
big jubilee lunch people across the uk
will celebrate at events in their own
communities from a mile-long street
party to backyard barbecues
and closing their festivities will be
the platinum jubilee pageant when
thousands of performers make their way
down the mall in central london
now today we'll also see senior royals
visiting all four uk nations the duke
and duchess of cambridge will be heading
to cardiff a spot likely chosen given
that william will inherit the title of
prince of wales when his father becomes
king dan whitehead has been in paul
talbot finding out what people there
think of the royal family
[Music]
in the shadow of the steel works a party
is underway
for camavin's community it's a chance to
raise a toast
but also reflect on what the monarchy
and specifically the role of prince of
wales means to those living here i am a
royalist
i think he has a role
um but we don't relate as much to him as
we do to them to the queen i think the
majority of people in wales do agree
with the monarchy i think he should be
the last prince of wales as much as we
respect him he hasn't done that much for
wales as a country you know he
very much represents great britain so i
think it's about time that we had
somebody to represent the country of
wales in wales
the royal title of the prince of wales
dates back to england conquering the
nation in the 13th century nowadays
while more symbolic some experts believe
attitudes to the title are changing if
we look back to say the victorian period
onwards um there has been a huge pride
within wales that the heir to the throne
was the prince of wales because it was
seen as something that made wales
important
as we move forward in time and kind of
welsh nationalism has grown
that kind of pride in it has ebbed away
somewhat it's become more controversial
a recent poll by cardiff university
found 55 percent of people in wales
support having a monarchy while 28
would rather have an elected head of
state
while it is of course a weekend of
celebrations the queen's milestone puts
into focus the role of the royal family
here in wales and for younger
generations just what the future of the
monarchy means to them
so who do you prefer charles or william
and kate
williams and why is that
because we both got williams in her
class
because
they've got kids
and
[Music]
i think perhaps the people's popular
choice would be william and kate because
they are younger perhaps we can relate
to them more they have young children
how important it is to wales um
i think it is really important actually
yeah i think it is part of the sort of
welsh identity
happy jubilee
the image of the royals differs between
the generations
and while there is support many feel the
monarchy's role in wales may need to
reform in the years to come
[Music]
and whitehead sky news in port albert
south wales
we've got more jubilee coverage to come
but first let's take a look at some of
the day's other
headlines and at least four people have
been killed and dozens of others have
been injured after a train derailed in
southern germany police say it had been
heading to munich and had been quite
full at the time that it crashed
prosecutors and police have started an
investigation into the cause of the
incident
uefa has sincerely apologized to all
fans affected by the chaotic events at
last saturday's champions league final
european football's governing body
announced on tuesday that it had
launched an independent review into the
access issues that led to fans being
crushed and tear-gassed outside stad de
france in paris before real madrid's
one-nil win against liverpool
the foreign secretary liz truss has
vowed that the uk will never stop
supporting ukraine in a statement
marking a hundred days of the war last
night she warned vladimir putin cannot
win
she also added that russia's unjustified
and illegal invasion threatened world
peace and economic stability
well i can give you the exclusive news
that it is likely raining here in
central london but let's get all the
rest of the weather now
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well high pressure will exert influence
over northern parts of the country for
the rest of the weekend whilst a
thundery low will spread into the south
from the near continent i think i might
be feeling that now
overnight low clouds will spread in
across eastern coast to reach some
central areas in the south torrential
heavy and occasionally thundery showers
will reach southernmost counties by dawn
the showers will have reached southern
and central wales as well as parts of
the midlands
the weather sponsored by qatar airworks
[Music]
hello very good morning it's just gone 6
30 you're watching sky news breakfast
live from buckingham palace and a
reminder of our top stories here for you
this morning buckingham palace has
confirmed that the queen will miss this
year's epsom derby due to ongoing
mobility issues
newly released video shows the 96 year
old monarch's lifelong love of horses
[Music]
and two future kings princes charles and
william will pay tribute to the queen on
stage at a concert tonight to celebrate
her 70 years on the throne
so let me bring back in now our royal
commentator vi countess hinchinbrook
julie montague who's with us throughout
the morning i'm very happy to say
so julie we were saying there in our
headlines the news that uh the queen
won't be attending the epsom derby this
afternoon we discussed it a little bit
earlier no doubt disappointing to her
but do you think that means that we
we're unlikely to see her again this
weekend well i think this is the
million-dollar question
will we see her tomorrow you know sort
of for the closing out of the four-day
celebration and i think that's what
everybody's trying to understand and i
don't think we're going to get an answer
i think it's a day-by-day sort of
issue really with her mobility and how
she's feeling and so that's why we're
finding out about you know her not
arriving or not being able to attend uh
certain events at the last minute so and
there were no real kind of guarantees
given at the start were they they've
kept everything open haven't they
because they've obviously realized that
she has got the mobility issues and it's
extremely tiring isn't it events like
these i mean just smiling and being nice
to people all day must be fairly of
course of course and you know the palace
was always very clear in their messaging
that they would hope that the queen
would be able to make certain events but
it was never a guarantee and if you just
look back yesterday at the service of
thanksgiving and we'd know about her
mobility issues that would have been you
know i think a real strain on her um
just
walking down to the front i think would
have been you know i quite difficult for
her so it does make sense and i think
spending the day at epson today would
have been another strain on her i think
she is and i think a lot of people are
hoping that she's saving herself and her
energy for tomorrow to be able to you
know give the nation and give the world
sort of another glimpse of her and uh
throughout this four-day celebration
sort of we're started with the queen and
i think everybody's hoping that we will
end with her as well well that's right
four three appearances rather on that
first day on on the thursday which which
some people were surprised that we saw
her as much as that then and today the
other
celebration today that's going on behind
the scenes is for lillibette's first
birthday lilibert being harry and
megan's a younger child um do we know
anything about whether the queen might
be involved in that might we see a
photograph of the queen with lillabets
and is this all this is all speculation
it's all speculation and but perhaps we
know that megan and harry are staying at
frogmore so they're very nearby
i would be surprised if um you know they
didn't somehow try to at least get in
there and have you know a cup of tea or
a cake with with granny so but that will
never be reported to us but they are you
know they are not in london megan and
harry they are very near to the queen
and it is lillabits first birthday we've
only seen one photo of her before and
that was that christmas card that they
put out i think a lot of people will be
hoping will they you know produce a
photo but i think we know the answer to
that no they are very very product
protective of you know their family and
if they've had this issue with security
in the past so i don't think anybody
should get their hopes up in seeing a
picture of lillabet and we're seeing one
picture that they did release but it's i
haven't seen many others so you're
you're right they are very cautious
about about that so we'll have to wait
and see
but let me just take a look back because
we're here of course to talk about the
queen's 70 years on the throne so let's
just take a look at some of the queen's
milestones and
this year she became the world's third
longest reigning monarch in history
over her 70 years of service the queen
has been served by 14 prime ministers
the first being winston churchill
there have also been 14 u.s presidents
during her reign with the exception of
one president lyndon b johnson she's met
all of them
the queen's been on
271 foreign trips visiting over 100
countries as monarch
she's only missed one christmas
broadcast during her seven decades on
the throne
and known of course for her love of
corgis the queen has owned more than 30
dogs most of them descending from her
first corgi which was gifted to her on
her 18th birthday in 1944.
i feel quite tired just reading all that
that is a lot of work over a lot of
years and it's a reminder isn't it that
she's been that constant throughout all
of our lives yeah i mean that was
extraordinary what um what you just said
i mean 14 prime ministers 14 presidents
you know 30 corgis
exactly but you know that's the
wonderful thing about the queen
and you know as an american sometimes i
wish that we had something or someone
like the queen who unifies
you know we're in this period now that
very divisive um you know with what
we've seen over the past couple of years
turbulence really past couple of years
with roy with war with a pandemic with
brexit but the queen has been this
constant she's a unifier and i think
she's not only a unifier here in this
country but around the world sometimes i
like to think of her as similar to the
dalai lama you know world recognition
and someone who really conveys this
compassion and kindness and steadfast of
hope for others because even amongst
people who answer the monarchy you'll
find very few people who don't have
enormous respect for her and recognize
her kind of unflinching sense of duty
and stoicism absolutely you know out on
the mall on thursday uh you know i was
out on the mall and there were you know
crowds and crowds of people and they
were all they all had different
political preferences but they were
unifying together because it was the
queen because the queen is a political
and she has been this constant source i
think of support and a real sense of
a a rock like a steadfast rock for
people to turn to in times of need and
for that comfort
well julie montague pleased to say that
you'll be back with us a little bit
later for a moment thanks very much
indeed
well while the queen may have to watch
today's events on tv from windsor the
nation will continue to come out over
the weekend and celebrate the 70 years
of her reign sky's home editor jason
farrell with the help of a morris miner
has been busy capturing the defining
moments of the elizabethan era
the queen comes from an era where things
were built to last
[Music]
a jubilee is a celebration not just of a
long lasting monarch but of where we've
come from and who we are today
seven decades ago the first type of
morris minor was rolling off production
lines post-war britain looked to the
future
and did so with a new youthful monarch
who'd served as a mechanic and truck
driver in the war
earning a respect within the military
that has only grown
our captain general um the person who we
work for effectively um in every way for
the longest time she's been um in charge
of the army it's who we all take our
commission for who signs our royal
warrants when we when we take the oath
so she means a great deal
[Music]
in abingdon near to where the morris
minor was made there's an exhibition to
celebrate this second elizabethan era
the queen's long reign is a living
thread to any moment in british history
since the war the queen opened this very
building in 1956
and she's been on a journey with us up
until present day opening scientific
establishments in the area
pandemonium paid a visit to the usa four
shaggy minstrels the beatles under her
reign britain has led the way to a more
creative liberal and open global society
but there's been a painful transition
[Applause]
from an industrial-led nation
to a more financial service-based
economy that has benefited some more
than others
globally the country's transitioned from
ruling nations to maintaining the
closest possible ties and in that the
queen's role as the head of the
commonwealth is seen by many as crucial
there was testament to it in the crowds
flocking to celebrate her life she came
to uganda we are from malawi some of us
malawi here we are just different
countries when we look at those those
trips that she did around the
commonwealth were they important do they
matter why do they matter they brought
you know love to the community they
brought the togetherness and knowing
that she's selfless traveling and making
impact to the globe through the waste
charitable deeds that's when we see
even new roads being built yes
everything is revamped everything is
renewed because the queen is coming
in uganda we had a queen's way
and that was the highway and it was a
beautiful way but when she goes royalty
means a new road
[Applause]
the queen can attract numbers that even
rock stars couldn't pull and in an
ever-changing world she remained
something familiar predictable
unchanging
so she still commands ceremonial majesty
and the crowd still stop and cheer when
her car unexpectedly arrives in the
palace entrance
70 years ago we lived in a country which
was bound by deference it was a class
within society as a society which was
very constrained and restrained the
monarchy now reflects as it did 70 years
ago
the society of 2022 and that takes a lot
of care and it takes leadership and i
think it was leadership of the queen in
particular to understand that changes
were required but in a very gradual way
in recent times the queen has remained a
symbol of unity addressing the nation
during covid she sent a reassuring
message we will be with our friends
again we'll be with our families again
we will meet again
and even setting an example at her
husband's funeral sat alone while the
world watched
but behind all the ceremony and
formality she has remained an enigma a
largely unknown woman
in a world that is now flooded with
opinion we still don't know what she's
thinking
jason farrell sky news
i'm very pleased to report that it has
stopped raining for the time being but
i'm going to fill you in on the rest of
the weather now across the country
[Music]
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well high pressure will exert influence
over northern parts of the country for
the rest of the weekend whilst a
thundery low will spread into the south
from the near continent
low cloud having spread across eastern
coast to reach some central areas will
give a dull start to the day in the
south torrential and occasionally
thundery showers will reach southernmost
counties
the weather sponsored by qatar airworks
[Music]
well coming up after the break we're
going to take you through all the
jubilee coverage in this morning's
papers and there's an awful lot of it
[Music]
well it's time to take a look through
the morning papers now and what they
made of yesterday's jubilee celebration
so here with me to go through the papers
are royal historians tessa dunlop and
kate williams very good to see you both
how are we enjoying the the festivities
so far this long weekend well it's been
spectacular it's been incredible and the
weather's played ball but i'm not sure
about today you just said it's raining
as you came out but it's it's it's
fitting very slightly i'm getting
slightly obsessed with this and i'm
giving regular updates of the weather
we'll go through your selections in just
a moment but first let's take a look
through those front pages shall we and
starting with the mirror together yet
apart the cambridges and the sussexes
all attending the queen's jubilee
service but still keeping their distance
and it's the same story on the front of
the mail so far apart is their headline
the times has words from the archbishop
of york as he pays tribute to an absent
queen at the saint paul's service
and that service is the front image on
the express this morning with the
headline we give thanks
and a similar sentiment leads the
telegraph thank you for staying the
course they say
the guardian meanwhile points out that
with no queen in attendance and the next
generation of royals gathering in her
place it seems like we were witnessing a
new age for the monarchy
and away from the jubilee the eye leads
with the leadership concerns within the
conservative party and a warning from
boris johnson's allies to the rest of
the party that without him at the helm
they'll lose
the financial times meanwhile reports a
multi-million pound lawsuit has been
filed against administrators of the
collapsed woodford stock market fund to
try the
recoup the money lost by investors
well the star reveals that beer bellies
are bad for your love life
i really hope we're talking about that
one i suspect we're not
not now no not now maybe we'll save that
up for later because um i want to know
the details of that one anyway we're
going to kick off with the a lot of the
papers dominated by the jubilee
celebrations the majority of them you
picked out the times arcade and this uh
their headline reflects what the
archbishop of york said yesterday at the
thanksgiving service well yes all the
papers huge jubilee coverage there are
post pictures so big of some of the
rules they could be posters and this
story from the times really is about the
archbishop's very last minute sermon the
archbishop of canterbury had covered so
the archbishop of york gave the sermon
talking about how the queen wasn't there
but is still in the saddle and really
reflects how she is isn't going to be
able to be at all these jubilee events
but it's still she's still the queen she
is not leaving she's not going anywhere
she's still here she's still a
significant figure and yet
obviously there was a poignancy to the
fact that the queen wasn't at her own
thanksgiving service and yet we did see
of course prince charles representing
her there and you're getting a sense
over this weekend aren't you with
princess anne stepping in at the epsom
derby this afternoon of a sort of
gradual handing over of some duty yeah
and i think in some ways that'll do
charles
favors and i think indeed it already has
we saw him opening parliament not so
long ago and then trooping the color
taking the salute and he's sort of
acquiring the trappings of state and you
sort of
grow with the institution in that
context and we see charles then in this
different more majestic setting and it's
less about the individual and more about
monarchy yeah interesting stuff and
another you wanted to focus in on um the
service itself and some it's hit some of
the front pages you've picked out and
the double page space spread as well in
the mail and basically the seating
arrangements please this is all about
the soap opera for some of the papers
they've got their long lenses in on lots
of different individuals i mean how are
you meant to sit for an hour plus long
service in some pools with ramrod
straight back eyes to the front if you
want in case someone snaps you yeah now
they make a big thing of this kind of
you know the brothers still apart well
the way it was choreographed you know
the sort of working roles were on one
side predominantly and the sussex is off
to another side with the sort of well as
richard k puts it he also runs of the
family which is a little bit harsh i
think for a dear thanksgiving service
but yeah william looking up to the gods
and likewise harry both sort of as if
they're staring for the answers and i
thought then it was rather sort of
poetically picked up that he wasn't
looking up at the gods boris johnson but
down at the floor in the long lens
picture of him and of course he was
booed as he went into
the cathedral and likewise when he left
and this has been picked up you know
sort of ceremonial celebration of
britishness predominantly female royal
fans outside the cathedral
normally a conservative prime minister
would expect something of a cheer
well yes and there were a few cheers i
think but there were also an awful lot
of booze weren't there and
what do you think kate about the seating
arrangement i mean was that purely
as per protocol they're not working raws
anymore the sussex so they were going to
be on the other side of the aisle or do
you think that was a deliberate attempt
to avoid uh the snappers and avoid any
kind of scrutiny of what conversations
they had with the rest of the family i
do think there's been any desire to find
a soap opera there because really there
was so much criticism before the sussex
has even arrived saying they might
overshadow and the reason why they might
overshadow is because everyone takes
pictures of them rather than the other
wars rather than charles and camilla and
everyone's so you know fascinated by
this soap opera and really underneath it
all i think what i saw there was a
family supporting the queen harry and
megan were there they seemed very happy
it was a family supporting the queen so
trying to find riffs and excess i think
is is sort of you know wild obsession
with sort of trying to really we're
following on from the long times in
which there's so much attack too many
attacks on megan but i think you know i
was out there buying some pauls and
there were huge cheers to the sussexes
when they arrived people were really
thrilled to see them back there's also
how do you spin the story i noticed that
some of the commentary of the family
going into the cathedral it was said
well the queen's given the sussex a
special chance so they can ceremonially
proceed down the aisle alone a moment to
themselves not just with all the rest of
the family and the cousins and yet if
you read some of the press today oh they
were demoted that's one of the headlines
they were demoted so it very much
depends you know who you believe and
what you choose which store you choose
to buy into interesting let's move on
because there's a story actually inside
the times isn't there that you wanted to
focus on and it's really a look back at
some of the key events in the queen's
life as i understand it yes so we've got
what we've got here is um this in the
times a big survey of what's going to be
going on today and tomorrow the derby
the platinum palace and the pageant so
the pageant on sunday well fingers
crossed it's going to be uh you know
we remember the diamond jubilee when we
were all out there
on the river and really it's going to
really commemorate not just the queen
but also her reign since 1952 and you
know there's going to be everything from
vintage cars to daleks and what i'm
fascinated by is in the state coach
we're going to see it's apparently going
to be a video of the queen which is
going to look completely realistic the
young queen waving a bit like the abba
you know i've got these abba uh
holographic avatars i'm wondering
whether this really is the future of
monarchy that she is the most traveled
queen she's been around the world 40
times maybe in the future we're going to
have monaco's an avatar well yes and
she'll probably be very grateful not to
be in that coach but i understand it's
incredibly uncomfortable well she says
i've not been in it it's so
uncomfortable and she said it was
horrible and the coach was not meant for
travelling in at all
better videos and arguably she could be
in the saddle forever if only requires a
whole girl
that's absolutely true now you you've
got a story in the eye that you wanted
to pick up on yeah this
i so i was at trooping the color and i
came out then onto the
inter trafalgar square and then tried to
get down whitehall and it was absolutely
packed uncomfortably so the police were
you know trying to keep us in i think
they didn't anticipate the numbers and
i've never actually experienced
something like that and it very much
made me think of champion champions
leagues fans in paris just last weekend
and how they were kettled in and then
there was tear gas and they finally
apologized uefa but being in a big crowd
now clearly that for some people is
absolutely where it's at the sort of
adrenaline the togetherness but it can
be uncomfortable and they're saying
there's going to be yet more crowds this
weekend no matter the weather more than
a million are to hit london and i just
hope the police are ready for this and
we know how to handle it a lot of roads
are going to be shut off so if you're
looking to travel through central london
don't do it by car i tried the bike a
couple of days ago and had really quite
a lot of success we've managed a traffic
report and a weather report as well as a
newspaper review you you guys are very
professional and i am going to see you
in in the next hour but for the moment
thanks both very much indeed